- Vayner Nation, got
a serious thing here.
Posted something
a couple days ago.
Danny, shh, I'm
making amazing content.
("Unstoppable" by This Is Wolff)
So I woke up super
early for a 4:30 A.M.
in Kansas City.
("Hit The Lights" by Rowlan)
Had a great
meeting last night with
a Fortune 500 CEO at his home.
Got on a plane,
connected to Detroit.
Just landed here
in Columbus, Ohio.
Had some Vayner
Sports business to be had.
Vayner Sports recruiting.
That's the
Barnes &amp; Nobles I did a
Thank You Economy
on that second floor.
Oh my god, I'm definitely doing
this Barnes &amp; Nobles for my
February book tour.
Yeah, I'm gonna
fuckin' blow that out.
- [DRock] Can you
imagine having all that film?
- And the recap,
imagine the recall right now.
Guys, you don't understand.
Hold on.
Oh yeah.
To finish this story...
Just been on a three hour
call just here for
Pencils of Promise.
Oh that's right, DRock, you were
filming so you probably have a
nice little time
lapse, little music.
("Hit The Lights" by Rowlan)
And now headed to Vegas for a
speech I'm giving tomorrow.
Been on the phone hard core.
Getting a real cadence.
I've always struggled to be on
top of my VaynerMedia business
when I travel to the level
that I've wanted but lately,
you know, you get better.
Getting better just
texting with the team.
Emailing,
really in the business.
A lot of new business for
VaynerMedia which is exciting.
Huge focus, I think you're
seeing in my Instagram Stories
and places of that
nature, on small business.
Really trying
to attack my roots,
trying to come up
with lower price point,
entry points for
people to work with Vayner.
Have a really cool launch
product called Vayner 101 that
I'm, it's a little bit weird
that I'm putting it out here but
I'm gonna come up with
something called Vayner 101.
It's gonna be
$101,000 at VaynerMedia.
Consulting
something that, you know,
something that I've seen
us sell for $300-400,000.
I'm refining it
down for a launch plan.
So many people have businesses
and they want to spend their
money on launching.
So a launch plan,
brand positioning,
first batch of
three months of content.
Signature piece of video.
So playing,
playing a lot with that.
What else is going on?
Speaking to a bunch of cool
celebs and influencers about
being guests on
The #AskGaryVee Show.
Obviously we're in that cadence.
Trying to answer
questions during DailyVee.
I think that's gonna be cool.
I'm excited about that.
- [Man] Yo Gary, if you
were 20 years old right now,
what would be your plan of
attack to reach the goals that
you currently have?
Thanks for the content.
- I mean look, if I'm 20 years
old and I know what my goals
are, I'm committed to them
blindly is I guess my answer.
I think the biggest thing that
I'm starting to recognize and
feel is I'm just binary.
Black and white.
Switch on or switch off.
Hustle mode, on.
I mean the amount of
people that are half pregnant,
kind of into it.
Sorta shoulda,
coulda, little, kinda.
I just think it's all-in and
so to be very frank with you,
brother, let me
pull up your account.
Let's see, The
Oyster River, that's cool.
I would, my man,
I would just go all-in.
I mean at 20, the hell,
(chuckles) you have your whole
life in front of you and why not
try to achieve greatness ASAP?
Like go for it.
Like just go for it blindly.
I wouldn't judge myself.
I would use my
fresh, naive eyes.
Experience is a
gift and a real leverage,
but naivete and blind faith and
not knowing the rules is also
a real advantage and so if I was
20 I would just get real serious
on my naivete and
go all-in blindly.
Run through the
wall and get it done.
I'd put in the work, man.
You're 20 you can live
on a lot less sleep at 20
than you can at 41.
DRock and I in our back
to back three hour days,
it's kinda tough.
Little rugged.
I'd go all fuckin' in, man.
("Hit The Lights" by Rowlan)
Vayner Nation, got
a serious thing here.
Posted something
a couple days ago.
Danny, shh, I'm
making amazing content.
I'm just kidding, I'm kidding.
I posted the other day
about the 18 hours things.
Put up the, can
you guys just put,
make it a fourth of the screen.
Show that video real
quick for a second on Instagram,
18 hours a day.
What do you do with it?
I was so intrigued by
how many people were like,
what the fuck, like you
need more than 6 hours sleep.
Or some of us have
to take care of things.
Or I'm a single dad,
like you're not factoring in.
I'm factoring in everything.
You know, for example,
I don't give a fuck.
Like sleep 10 hours a day.
Then all I'll say to
you is you have 14 hours.
To me this is not
about the semantics.
This is about the binary mindset
of winning or losing in life.
Everybody's looking for excuses.
You responding in that
comments of but what about this,
but what about that,
but what about this,
fuck that or I need more time or
people need more time
or this is unfair.
What about whiffle ball or
escapism or family time or,
excuses.
If you want to achieve
what you want to achieve
at the highest level.
This is a binary game.
Either you're in the, yes,
I will figure this out business
or no, this won't work because.
Too many of you are
stuck, fucking stuck,
in this is not
going to work because.
You're still bitter.
You're upset.
You're still upset
that girl broke up with you.
That's why it's not happening.
You're upset because your
parents didn't have any money
and you have to
pay for it yourself.
Like you're upset.
And you're in the I can't
have this work out because.
You actually got upset that
the number was 18 hours a day.
You have time to do instead
of realizing that's not what
I fucking gave a fuck about.
It's just maximizing what
you can do while you're awake.
So whether you're
sleeping six, seven,
eight, nine or ten
hours, that's fine.
I'm just interested in
what you're doing in the 14,
15, 16 hours you have
to do something about it.
But what I'm way
more interested in is
why do you have so
much poison in you?
Why do you have so
much negativity in you?
Why are you losing?
Why is that your mindset that
as soon as you see anything,
forget about my content.
I'm a little
bit of a weird dude.
I went out and looked at
what you did other places.
You're just in the no business.
You're in the defense.
You're in the I can't
because business and
that's a fucking losing game.
So please use this little
backseat rant to figure out
what's inside of you that's
making you go there and fix that
because all my content,
all these courses,
all your business ideas,
all your wants and ambitions,
aren't going to mean jack
shit if you don't fix that.
- [DRock] Tell me
how you really feel.
- That.
("Hit The Lights" by Rowlan)
- [DRock] How are you?
- [Gary] Me?
I'm great.
I'm always good.
Until the end.
'Cause I'm driven by
gratitude, perspective.
Yep.
I just know what it's about.
I'm good.
Forever.
Shit is binary, baby.
Either you're in or out.
I'm just in.
And most people are out.
("Hit The Lights" by Rowlan)